so hello
my name is amy briggs manyaza vootsami
briggs
[Music]
i'm dusting off my very rusty college
russian because this story starts in
siberia back in 1988
when archaeologists hit the jackpot they
were looking for kurgans
burial mounds of an ancient nomadic
culture known as scythians
and they found one from about 2500 years
ago
[Music]
in one of the burials there was a
tightly closed hollowed-out log
with a well-preserved mummified body of
a child
he runs the historical genetics lab at
the moscow institute of physics and
technology
the burial he's talking about was
remarkable it was intact and its
contents were so well preserved that
even a fur
coat and a leather cap were recognizable
they also found weapons next to the
child a real bow
a quiver with arrows a battle axe
everything indicated that the young
warrior was a boy
thirty years later archaeologists wanted
to know what could modern genetics tell
us about this kid and his ancestry
so the case of the scythian warrior boy
landed on karis's desk
[Music]
with tissue taken from the burial a
tooth all the action happens inside
small boxes
they're filled with nitrogen and the
contents are then completely sealed so
that nothing contaminates the dna
keras needed to find the y chromosome
the one that males typically have and
females don't
luboy paprika vigilante
any attempts to isolate the y chromosome
from the sample were unsuccessful
and we were very worried because this
was our first trial experience of
working with a sample of this age
this is the 7th century bc we're talking
about and the feeling of failure made us
very unhappy
emotions started to run high the team
was determined to prove they could
analyze
that tooth but no matter where they
looked they couldn't find the y
chromosome
at some point we got the emotions under
control and just looked straight at the
data
and that's when he realized what was
staring him right in the face
the reason karis couldn't find the y
chromosome because it wasn't there that
tooth never had a y chromosome to begin
with
and that's because this wasn't a warrior
boy that caris was working with
it was a warrior girl
[Music]
i'm amy briggs executive editor of
national geographic history
and this is overheard at national
geographic a show where we eavesdrop on
the wild conversations we have at nachio
and follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world
this week meet the warrior women
overlooked by history
and how science is helping us see the
past more clearly
more after the break
warrior women were always kind of a
thing with me growing up there were
plenty to choose from
you had princess leia charlie's angels
miss piggy
but top of the list was probably wonder
woman she had bulletproof bracelets
the lasso of truth super strength
invisible jet
she had it all so wonder woman was an
amazon and her origin story tied back to
the female warriors of ancient greek
myth
so i had always wanted to do an amazon
story for national geographic history
magazine and we decided to publish one
so when that time came around
we knew exactly who to call
i have always been interested in amazons
and i actually began
by drawing them and making etchings of
amazons because i love their costumes
and the way they were portrayed as
these strong independent women this is
adrienne mayer
she's a classic scholar at stanford and
devoted to all things amazon
in ancient legends the amazons were
strong brave
skilled at combat and riding horses and
they fought as well as men
but they weren't from greece according
to the myths
they were from the outskirts of the
so-called known world and adrian learned
that to tell their
story you have to be a tough woman
yourself decades ago
she fixated on this legendary battle
when an amazon army invaded athens
and i proposed an article to military
history quarterly in 1990
and said that we have so many details
from the ancient writers
about this battle that i could make
battle maps
and analyze the strategy
of the amazons and the athenians in this
famous
mythic battle oh that's so cool and it
was turned down
but i had a plan i asked my husband to
serve as my co-author so i proposed it
again
we proposed it he proposed it with his
name first in mind
second the exact same proposal and they
accepted it
oh get out of town
so so that's the first article i wrote
and she never really stopped writing
about them luckily there's plenty of
material to cover
so let's say you lived in ancient greece
in its heyday you know about 2500 years
ago
tales of gods and monsters and heroes
all the myths that we know today
they were kind of like pop culture to
them and the amazons
they were the opponents and sometimes
lovers of greece's greatest heroes
like the warrior achilles who'd battled
pimphacilia during the trojan war
i don't know if that's how you say that
i think it's penthouse
okay i got it let's try this one more
time
and the amazons they were the opponents
and sometimes lovers of greece's
greatest heroes
like the warrior achilles who battled an
amazon named penta solea during the
trojan war
in one story the greek hero theseus
teams up with heracles
who you may also know as hercules
these heroes got together a bunch of
other heroes and they went to
help heracles on his mission to get the
war belt of
queen hippolyta of the amazons they
lived on the black sea
this amazon colony ruled by queen
hippolyta
and her sister antiopi well
heracles uh actually
dueled with hippolyta and and killed her
and took the war belt meanwhile theseus
the founder of athens was fighting with
antiope
they were equally matched but theseus
actually
won and took antiope captive as a
as a prisoner of war and married her
so now athens is ruled by king theseus
and his amazon
wife which is very exciting for the
greeks
greeks ate up stories like that and
adrian says
the archaeological record makes it clear
that amazon's occupied a big place in
the ancient greek imagination
they even show up on the most important
building in athens the parthenon
the pictures of amazons and images of
amazons and
and battles with amazons were everywhere
in athens they were on frescos and
public walls and paintings in
people's houses and on pottery
if you were looking at a piece of
ancient greek pottery it's pretty easy
to pick out the amazons
first of all they're women second
they're decked out for battle you'll see
them wearing helmets tunics
and pants they're carrying weapons bows
and arrows
spears and sometimes even axes which are
pretty cool
and third more often than not they're
shown doing what they do best
fighting other real enemies of the
greeks say the
like the persians when they're depicted
in vase paintings fighting with greeks
they are running away in fear cowering
in fear
or gesturing for mercy and amazons
are never doing that they're always
running toward
danger and they never gesture for mercy
so
amazons were shown as just as heroic and
courageous
as the greek male warriors
the amazons were so pervasive in great
culture there were even action figures
and we also know that little girls
played with amazon dolls
clay dolls some of them with moving legs
and arms
and that you could you could actually
dress them in different costumes and
they're holding weapons
and they have helmets and they've been
found in little girls
graves
but the greek fascination doesn't mean
they were totally comfortable with the
idea of female warriors
especially in their own culture amazons
couldn't be any more different from the
greek women they knew
proper greek women were expected to stay
indoors most of their lives
or in the you know portico a protected
courtyard
weaving and minding children they didn't
live
the active outdoor life participating in
the same activities as the men
in greece and that stark difference made
a deep impression on the greeks
this difference did inspire admiration
but
not imitation i found out about this
when we were searching for images for
adrian's magazine story
one of my favorites wound up on the
cover it was from a terracotta jug
and the scene shows a woman thrusting a
spear at a man holding a shield and a
sword
she's fully clothed and the greek guy
well he's not wearing anything except
his helmet
the cover image we have is a fully
dressed woman and she's battling a
totally naked greek guy
i love it it's so funny because
classical vase scholars would say that
the male greek heroes are always dressed
in a costume
of heroic nudity and the ancient greeks
uh they thought that wearing trousers
was one of the most barbaric things you
could do it's just
outrageous that you would be covering
your entire body
in this way so the greeks surrounded
themselves with depictions of these
so-called barbarians
almost like they were creating a
thrilling alternate universe
i think the myths also offered a kind of
safe way
for ancient greeks to sort of escape
their male
dominated patriarchal culture and rise
above
that kind of society and imagine what it
might be like for men and women to be
equals
a world where men and women are equals
sounds nice right
well for a long time one group of people
had a hard time imagining it
classical scholars according to adrian
the accepted wisdom passed down through
the ages went like this
the amazons were fictional characters
fantasies
that were brought into existence just so
they could be killed off by greek heroes
the only good amazon is a dead amazon
when did
scientists start to take you know amazon
warriors more seriously a subject that
they were a real
thing than a myth well i would say that
that didn't happen until
until archaeologists began applying
bioarchaeology and dna to the skeletons
that they were finding in scythian
graves
those are the same techniques we heard
about in that russian lab
adrian says that kind of dna work
started as early as the 1990s
but genetics research has come a long
way since then
and charis mustafin the russian
geneticist says the field of
bioarchaeology is only going to get
better
at the
it's a natural science that allows
historians and archaeologists to get new
data
that will allow them to see the true
history by correcting
or radically
using ancient dna like karis's team's
work with the scythian burial
is just one example of helping revisit
the distant past
to correct some old ways of thinking
like the presence of weapons in a burial
meaning it belonged to a man
[Music]
partner while we deeply respect our
partner archaeologists
we understand that genetic studies are a
powerful tool
which in some cases can correct errors
kara says that moving forward
his lab has added a new step to their
process now after they extract dna
they test the sex of every sample they
analyze with this new data in mind
when we look back at the scythian burial
and see all the weapons buried with that
young girl
it paints an entirely different picture
of the women who lived thousands of
years ago
[Music]
so how do real scythians measure up
against the stories about the amazons
more after the break
starting about 2 700 years ago we know
that the scythian people lived all over
asia
and the lands around the black sea where
the greeks said the amazons lived
and all the way east to mongolia and
north to siberia
they lived a nomadic life riding across
wide open grasslands
called steps you're in a small group on
the on the harsh steps the
climate is harsh the topography is harsh
you're always on the move
facing constant thread of of enemies
that means that everyone male and female
young and old
everyone's a stakeholder everyone's
expected to take part in defense and
raids and hunting and all those
activities
so it was natural and necessary to teach
the boys and girls
the same skills the same horse riding
hunting
fighting skills from day one
archaeologists could see that scythian
people were warlike
many of their burials included lots of
weapons and their bodies often had signs
of serious injuries
like broken ribs or fractured skulls
like the amazons the scythians were
expert equestrians
which explains the pants you can see on
all those greek phases
the greek concept of heroic nudity just
doesn't work on horseback
and of course if you're going to do that
you have to have trousers or leggings
and so they invented the world's first
tailored garments
if you think about it the greeks and
egyptians they're all
wearing big rectangles of cloth pinned
together
the scythians are wearing tailored
garments
so horses and pants check
another amazon skill according to the
myths archery
the scythians were expert archers too
and they were known for using what's
called a recurve bow
which is a smaller bow that's sort of
shaped with curves
like like you imagine a cupid's bow
and this this kind of bow a recurve bow
is great for
using on horseback because it's small
but it carries a huge amount of power
stores a lot of power and this is the
equalizer
this combined with horse riding
this bow is the equalizer for women
in scythian culture you put a girl or a
woman
on a horse with a recurve bow she can be
just as fast
just as deadly as any boy or man
here's just one example of how deadly a
scythian could be
scythians had a signature move called
the parthian shot
okay so imagine you're on a horse you're
in battle you're galloping at top speed
and you grab your bow
and arrow but instead of shooting
forward you turn around
and fire off a volley behind you without
slowing down
and if that weren't enough scythians
were reported to dip their arrows in
snake venom
to make them poisonous
when adrian and i spoke for this episode
we were still under covet 19 protocols
so we were zooming but that didn't stop
her from giving me a guided tour of her
house and all the cool amazon stuff in
it
she has amazon artifacts sprinkled all
over the place
little figurines with historically
accurate costumes
this is a very famous full-size statue
in
berlin but this is a bronze copy
of a life-size statue of an amazon
spearing a lion
these works of art were everywhere in
her office on her coffee table on the
walls
but there was one thing i couldn't wait
to see the weapons
so there was a documentary made in
kazakhstan
about the original amazon scythian
warrior women and i was the consultant
for the equipment
and the script and the weapons and
instead of being paid
in money i asked for some props that's
how adrian ended up with scythian battle
gear
she held up a dagger a quiver of arrows
and then
the great equalizer i'll have to set my
phone down to bring it up
oh wow this is the bow they were made
with
many layers of larch wood which takes
years to dry and it gives it that
springiness so that it will
store a lot of power these objects that
adrian surrounded herself with remind
her that there was a time when women and
men played on the same battlefield
literally my own dream
has always been for equality so the
relatively egalitarian culture
of the of the amazons and then the real
step nomads who were the model for the
amazons
that really struck a chord with me that
kind of equality
you can even find it in ancient sources
the greeks weren't the only ones who
wrote about the scythians
you find them in ancient persian texts
also egyptian and chinese
and if you look beyond the greeks you
see a picture that looks a lot more
realistic
they have their heroes fighting the
women but they're so equally matched
they fall in love and then they go off
to win victories and suffer defeats and
and live to fight again so i i just
think it's really amazing that outside
of
of the greek culture in greek mythology
beyond the greek world
women warriors and male warriors could
make love and war together as equals and
then even sometimes live happily ever
after
according to adrian there's no doubt
that the real life encounters with
scythian women
inspired the greek amazon stories the
amazons were more than myth
they were real
it took something as powerful as dna to
undo centuries of accepted wisdom
it's just nourished the good thing about
natural scientific methods
is that they can be verified the dna
analysis that happens in karis
mustafin's lab
he says it can overturn outdated ways of
seeing the world
and as researchers get better he's sure
we'll find even more stories that we've
gotten wrong
we just don't know what they are yet
these are new methods previously
inaccessible to researchers
who now can shed light on certain
historical processes
the formation of nations civilizations
states
so that people know about their past
it helps check our present day biases
though yes for one we're already
learning that scythian women weren't
alone
modern analysis shows that women fought
alongside men all over the ancient world
from peru to china to pre-rome in italy
women today are no less powerful than
men
and perhaps it's important that we have
a model in an ancient society to look
back to
and validate and confirm
[Music]
are still at work analyzing the young
warrior girl but this time
they're not just looking into the girl's
paternal lineage they're looking for
details about her mom's side too
because otherwise they'd only have half
the story
[Music]
more after this
[Music]
if you'd like to dive even deeper into
the world of amazons check out our show
notes for a story about the hidden
meaning of amazon names
there are some fun ones like hot flanks
and don't fail
for subscribers you can check out the
full history magazine cover story that
adrian wrote
and we also have photos of modern
warrior women all around the world
taken by photojournalist lindsay adario
also adrienne's written a whole book
about these amazons
it's called the amazons lives legends of
warrior women across the ancient world
that's in our show notes right there in
your podcast app
[Music]
overheard at national geographic is
produced by laura sim brian gutierrez
jacob pinter
carla wills and alana strauss jacob
pinter also edited this episode
our senior editor is eli chen our
executive producer of audio is devara
ardulon
our fact checkers are julie beer
michelle harris and robin palmer
our copy editor is amy kolczak and
hansdale sue designed and engineered
this episode
he also composed our theme music this
podcast is a production of national
geographic partners
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
susan goldberg is national geographic's
editorial director
and i'm your host amy briggs thanks for
listening and see you all next time
[Music]
you